WILLIAM LI: Well, I
think the first thing
to say in terms of
tips for educators
is to really encourage you or
really encourage them to do it.
It's a very
rewarding experience.
I think that the opportunity
to engage with community
organizations and assistive
technology users--
people with disabilities
in the wider community,
beyond a college
campus-- is for us
as instructors a very rewarding
and exciting experience.
And you also find within
the university itself
a lot of support and
interest-- people
who want to bring
their own experiences
or different aspects of the
university that maybe work
in assistive technology
or Student Disability
Services that really get
very excited-- or in design,
or in engineering, and so on.
And the students
themselves, I think
it's really a special
group of students who
are interested in this topic.
I think that's really
probably the biggest
kind of joy of working
in a class like this--
the kind of experiences
that students
bring to the table,
the dedication
that they bring to the class.
So there's sort of a
big need out there.
There's sort of a big
interest from students.
The other core part I would
say is, there's no doubt,
I mean logistically it's
always a lot of work
to bring together--
different partners
or find people out
in the community,
and find lab spaces and places
to build prototypes, and so on.
And I wouldn't
even claim that we
tried to make it particularly
efficient this year.
I think to us, particularly
given the circumstances
and given that we were doing
this for the first time,
we tried a lot of
experiments that did
require more time to set up.
That might be one
thing to say to
that-- there might be more
sort of efficient ways
to put this all together.
But the big thing
that I think comes
to mind is that it's
really the students working
with their client--
or it's really
the results of this interaction
between the students
and their client that
really motivates students
to learn, and to
develop new skills,
and to put a lot of time and
effort into their projects.
I really think that the way the
relationship between clients
and students is set up
really drives the course.
It's really the clients that
work with the students who
do a really substantial part
of the teaching associated
with the class.
So in terms of learning
outcomes or in terms
of the things that students
learn in the class is really
big gains, I guess, to be
gotten from a setup like this.
GRACE TEO: I have two
tips for other educators.
I think the first one is,
before the semester starts do
all your homework
as to where all
the resources within
your school are
and within your community,
because you have no idea where
the projects are going to go
and what help your students are
going to need.
There is no way
that you yourself
are going to possibly have
all the skills to teach them
how to do things.
So just make as many friends as
possible, who are on your side
and who are willing to
help out the students
with their projects.
The second tip is that
80%-- 70% to 80% of the work
is all about people management.
At the end of the
day, you're trying
to facilitate students
working for a client.
And the students are
usually novices at this.
And most of the trouble that
the students have come down to,
the client wants this, or
the client is doing this,
and it's very
discouraging, or we don't
know how to do this for them.
And so being able to
facilitate that relationship
becomes a big part of the work.
WILLIAM LI: One other
tip I would share
is really in terms of
the setup of the class.
I think we really do
believe that working
with the real clients
over the semester
is really at the core of this,
as opposed to maybe working
more theoretically in terms
of assistive technology design
or kind of a generalized
more abstract need.
I think what I've seen
is that really sharpens
the particular
need that students
identify and try to fulfill.
It certainly motivates
students to try
to get their project working.
And it also just
ends up, I think,
being just a stronger
learning experience
for everybody
involved-- just kind
of that human side of things.
So I know there's a lot of
moving parts in the class
that we've put
together this semester.
But from what I've seen, I
think working with a client,
and I think that associated
with that is the efforts
to identify the right groups
of people to work with, I think
is really important.
And I think there's some
question always about, well,
if you work with one
particular person,
does that mean you
sort of overfit
to that particular person?
Is this kind of
product only going
to be useful to that one
person in the world perhaps?
And the answer might
be, yes, sometimes.
I mean, it's very customized
and it works, hopefully,
for that particular person.
And intrinsically, I'd argue at
least that that's a good thing.
But the other
aspect-- and I think
a student wrote about this
in one of the blog posts--
is that I think doing this
kind of design for one
and making it work
end to end really
can be a successful way of
teaching design or teaching
engineering and
could lead as well
to kind of successful ideas
or successful solutions
in assistive technology
that are applicable to more
than one person.